we're now turning to chapter 8 which is
on linear equations
so linear functions linear equations
we'll look at these so we'll start with
defining linear functions now
we have looked at linear functions
before but that was a mapping from a
vector to a scalar
we're now going to look at functions
that map vectors to vectors
so this notation f colon
r rn to rm is complicated but pretty
universal and it means
it says that f is a function that maps
uh an n vector the first thing tells you
what it takes as an argument or input
and the second one over here our m tells
you
that's the set of m vectors and it says
that what f returns
or gives or yields or its output
is an m vector so that's it so this just
says it's it's a some function that maps
you know n vectors to m vectors okay
now we can write this lots of different
ways right so sometimes people write it
this way
you could write it as the m vector where
f one
you would say is the first component of
the function f and it's if that's of
course also a function of x so you write
it this way
and that emphasizes the components of f
of x the m different components of f
x now we can also write uh f of x
as f of and we can give instead of
giving a vector argument
we can give a list of scalar arguments
um
and that's f of x 1 up to x n just so
you can see that it's
to emphasize the fact that x is a vector
with n components
we generally we generally
will switch between these notations
without saying anything
okay now f satisfies the so-called
superposition property if the following
holds for any vectors
x and y these are n vectors and for any
constants or scalars alpha and beta it
says that
f of alpha x plus beta y
is equal to alpha f of x plus beta f of
y and you know when you look at this
equation very easy to kind of say yeah
sure or whatever
um but let's let's actually take a look
at what actually happened i mean you can
think of it this way
the alpha came out right um
and the plus also uh you know sort of
roughly speaking came out of f or
something like that
um and we can think of it this way so
one way to say it is that
this is forming a linear combination of
x and y with coefficients alpha and beta
and this the left hand side says form a
linear combination of x and y
then apply f the right hand side is
super interesting it says
first apply f both to x and to y then
form
the linear a linear combination with the
same coefficients and what it says is
that these
these two things if if f satisfy
superposition
what it means is that these two things
give the same result and
so roughly speaking it says something
like this
uh it means that f commutes with forming
linear combinations
something like that right because it
says i can form the linear combination
first then a play f
or i can apply f to each of the
arguments and then and then form a
linear recombinant and
i get the same thing okay so now of
course
certainly not all functions satisfy this
so this is a very special thing
if a function satisfies this it's called
a linear function
and that's kind of just universal across
mathematics comes up
in tons of fields right so that's the
idea that's what it means to be linear
it says
that this very special thing holds um
this is probably a good time for us to
just very quickly audit
that equation um let's at least let's do
at least a syntax
audit a syntax audit says there's a
whole bunch of stuff in there and you
better be able to identify what each
each individual part and subpart
of the equation is and make sure
everything is like cool
okay so here for example
x is an n vector so is y alpha
x is scalar vector multiplication of an
n vector
so that's an n vector so is beta y then
this plus is the plus between n vectors
now remember we overload plus so we put
plus innocently between all sorts of
things
and we kind of expect you to figure out
which plus
is it is it the plus between two numbers
between two m vectors between two n
vectors
in this case it's the plus between two n
okay so the whole thing alpha x plus
beta y is an n vector
we put that into f as the argument and
that's good because we look up f
and it says f takes as argument and n
vector so it's a good thing we're
passing it in
by the way if it weren't then we would
be committing a syntax there'd be a
syntax error here
okay and this tells you
that when when you give f a proper n
vector
f of that n vector is an m vector and so
the whole left hand side here
is that's an m vector okay cool let's
audit the other side just for syntax
well
f of x we check that that's correct
because x is an n vector and sure enough
f maps n vectors to m vectors so f x
that's an m vector
that's also an n vector then alpha
times f of x is actually scalar vector
multiplication
but for m vectors so alpha f of x and
beta f of y
are both m vectors and this plus is the
plus between two
m vectors not n vectors so so anyway
this is kind of thing and and then of
course the whole equation is cool
because on the left and the right hand
side
what you have is an m vector and we're
asserting that they're equal so
obviously if they were different sizes
and we were saying they were equal it
wouldn't even make sense
okay so all right so you may have seen
this in other
fields you've certain you know maybe
you've seen this in physics mechanics
other areas but comes up a lot the idea
of a linear
function okay
so let's look at a very specific
linear function you could even say it's
the prototype or the most obvious one
it's actually matrix vector
multiplication
okay so uh let's think of an m by n
matrix a
and we're going to define a vector a
function f as f of x equals ax now
remember what it means if i
say f is a function mapping r n to r
m then i have to tell you what f of x is
for any argument x which is an n vector
and what i'm saying is
you just multiply by a and that's what
it does so that that's called the matrix
vector product
function it's a linear function that's
super duper important and we can sort of
check it because
f of a alpha x plus beta
y is a times this argument and now we're
going to use some properties of matrix
vector multiplication right
so for example it distributes across the
plus
in the first one the alpha scalar
multiplication it commutes with so i can
pull the alpha out
and we recognize ax as f x and a y as f
y and sure enough this is superposition
uh holds okay now it turns out
as with the inner product uh function
uh for for a linear function mapping an
n vector to
a real number it that holds here too
in other words that if if a function is
linear
then it is actually given by
multiplication by
a matrix and we can even say exactly
what the
what x is uh what sorry what the matrix
a is
the matrix a uh has columns given by
f of e1 f of e2 up to f of en that's it
so that is the idea
now this app by the way has lots and
lots of applications uh so
it says for example that if i tell you
that that a a mapping
from our end rm is is linear it says
that
in principle you only have to make uh
and
you do n experiments right so you you
you plug in e1 and you get this
you plug in e2 you get that and you you
plug in
n you know different things e1 up to en
you form this matrix once you've got the
matrix you don't have to go back to your
experimental apparatus anymore
all you need to do is multiply by this
this matrix vector
and you will you will get i mean if it's
really linear
you will actually get what would have
happened had you gone in and actually
carried out the experiment
so that's uh that it's got a lot of
applications like that
okay so let's look at some examples um
oh
one of the things you are going to need
to do absolutely is to be able to
recognize
uh linear functions uh from that map rn
to rm you have to be able to recognize
them and
you have to so is if i i could describe
a function and you would say is it
linear or not linear
linear means it satisfies superposition
and it means it has a matrix vector
represent
a multiplication representation
and you have to be able to go like back
back and forth right you should be able
to see the matrix a
and then at least say what does ax do
now sometimes it's not easy to say in
english what it does but a lot of times
it actually is so let's look at some
examples so
here is this i would call that like the
reverser function or the reversal
function
so what it does is it takes a vector
which is x1 up to xn
and it spits out the vector sort of in
the opposite order so it's xn
xn minus 1 down to x1 okay so whatever i
mean
if this was a time series this would
give you the time reversal
or something i don't know what it is it
doesn't matter okay well
it turns out that that that's linear and
in fact it's given by
f of x equals ax with this a okay
now honestly that's pretty clear because
you should also be able if i showed you
that matrix a
you should develop the skill where you
see that a and immediately you'd i've
said what is it what you would even say
that's
a that's a reverse or a rever a reversal
matrix right
because let's see why because if i
multiply a
times x you know if i put an x1
up to xn here right and now i have
ax and you just look at the first you go
i go across the first row and down here
and i get this is equal to uh xn
okay then the second one is going to be
xn minus 1
and all the way down to the first one
and you can see that's that that's
x1 oh by the way this reverser matrix
is a select or matrix because each entry
each row is a unit vector and in fact
what it is is it's the unit vectors kind
of in reverse order
that's what it is okay so that's an
example of a linear function
and it's matrix representation um here's
another one running sum
so here's x1 then it's x1 plus x2 then
x1 plus x2 plus x3
and so on all the way up to the whole
sum that's the running sum
thing and that is also linear and it is
given by this matrix and you should be
able to see that as well
because if i multiply a times a vector x
then
the first one i'm just going to read it
from here is x1 then x1 plus x2
then x1 plus x2 plus x3 and this would
come up for example if x
is a cash flow with positive meaning for
example
cash coming to you and negative meaning
a payment you make
then you would say that if you apply
this matrix
which some people would call the running
sum matrix if you apply that matrix to a
cash flow
what you're going to get is the
so-called cumulative cash flow
so that would tell you it tells you that
for example the
the third the third entry of the
cumulative cash flow is the sum of the
first
three right so for example if it's an
investment
uh then you would say that the
cumulative cash flow
uh tells you what your uh net
payment uh payment to you is
at that time right so a typical
investment might involve
let's say a negative number which is
investment in a project
then it might even have two or three
negative numbers and that's that's you
putting money
into the project then well we hope uh
some of the later entries become
positive
and that's you kind of being paid back
those would be called disbursements
uh from your project or something and
the running sum
tells you kind of where do you stand
when the running sum is negative it
means that at that moment in time
you put more into that project than you
got out when it becomes positive
you would say cool i'm in the black and
you know well it may go down again but
it that's the point that's kind of the
idea okay so this comes up in a lot of
areas as well the idea of a running sum
matrix but again
it's linear and it's got it's associated
with this matrix here
and these are examples where you will
absolutely need the skill
to go back and forth between matrices
uh sort of an english description like
running sum
or reversal and then sort of a
mathematical description
that sort of tells you what it does
right so here's here's here's something
that tells you what running sum is
okay now
affine functions are very closely
related to linear functions um
and it's the same as an affine you know
it's a generalization of an affine
function that maps a vector into a
scalar which we already looked at
that works like this a function is
affine
if it's a linear function plus a
constant now
in this case the constant is a vector
and in fact it's an m vector
okay and it turns out that that's the
same as
as have it as satisfying as a restricted
superposition property and that
restricted property is this
it says the superposition holds period
uh for a linear function it's for any
alpha and beta
however for an affine function it's only
for alpha and beta that add up to one
right so if you like uh remember that a
linear combination where the
coefficients add up to one is sometimes
called a mixture
right like you know a 70 30 mixture
would be 0.7
you know uh and then 0.3 but you can
also have weird things like a 130
percent that's 1.3
and minus 0.3 that's called a mixture so
it says that superposition holds for
mixtures
all right now in this case as well um it
turns out that if you are if you're an
affine
if if if you are an affine function
we can actually represent it always as a
x plus b and we can get a
and b from f and the way we do that is
we evaluate f of zero
and then we evaluate uh f of one f of
two f of e one
f of e two and so on up to f of e n we
said
and then we get a directly and you can
just sort of check that if
f is affine then uh f
of x is equal to ax plus b where that
with this
f with this a and this b uh
now as with uh as with linear functions
scalar valued linear functions it's
common for people to call
um when they're being informal or
something like that
it's common to refer to an affine
function as linear right
and so whatever um
just be aware of that that some people
refer to that as a
two uh affine functions as linear and
then you'd say that's not
if you stop them and say hey that's not
uh that's that's not uh
linear that's a fine they'll say yeah
whatever so
um but but it's incorrect i mean so
whatever you should say something maybe
it depends on the social situation
whether you should say something or not
um okay